point shot four point nine seconds
that's plenty of time for wall and here
he is this up to three watches star the
field goal he's fouled on the play and
will have a chance for a four-point play
wall picked his pocket
that's his third field wall behind the
top that makes it one
Elementary
tipped up by Perkins no good Washington
going to try and get one off wall to the
town's got it baby John
alive and well in Washington ball rolls
balls up like Dickens I'm getting run
out picked up at the far end a quiet
ball game look at this look at this he
was spending on one way and Matt Barnes
head will spin on the other that's kind
of cool
Wow
[Music]
it's pulled down by cutler small driving
the lane puts it up John Wall has all
eight points in the corner for
Washington's been unstoppable in the
quarter
that's all eight of Washington sports
he's got 25 for the game quickly the
wall god pulls up for three
[Applause]
been sensational confusion on the part
of the bases defense good pick set
actually wasn't that good of a pick
George Hill could have gotten around
that but he kind of stopped and you can
see Allen a little hesitated coming out
job docks down to three to tie this
thing up here in the second attempt
suspend time John
[Music]
a slick packs inside for the easy deuce
shins and what a job or getting into the
paint mining his teammates in court I'm
delivering Washington is sticky stuff
power
[Applause]
accelerate
[Applause]
and then go into the basket drawn
[Music]
[Applause]
to give the Wizards the lead by one with
12 point seven seconds to play one Honda
drive of the game
22 points from wall he's got 12 here in
the fourth quarter obviously if it's a
tie game that you'd like to eat a little
more time and either going to overtime
or win it but when you're down one you
can't afford to do that missed it
knocked away from him wall has it
backing up Smith goes around the back
lays it up for the field goal and he'll
go to the line
oh what a move play it off the glass one
not easy to do behind the bag just
caught Smith totally flat-footed and the
two and that's a Honda drive of the game
executed beautifully for John Wall
trying to knock the ball away from
Fournier the Wizards get another steal
whoa behind his back and lays it in he
just danced pass to buy his Harris
Washington 6 of 8 from the field at 75%
wall up port lost possession now he
scores John Wall who practices shooting
with a left hand before the game had his
chance and he knocked it down he's in
the left hand
Oladipo is all over his right his
momentum is going to the left that's the
only way to release the shot what a
great shout from John Wall haven't seen
him do that before officials are coming
over to take a look at it
the unforced turnover wall drives lays
it up and with an acrobatic shot John
and Milwaukee takes time urged with a
7-nothing run after the Bucks scored
eight straight points the good job and
keep the ball away wall driving
attacking
backed up by quartet kept alive inside
corner stores at the
he has just been at the right place at
the right time all night long the pickle
well here's that last offensive
possession the airport ER is lurking and
remember when you get those second
opportunities with the heavy schedule
coming up I'm surprised he's getting
back nicely done that time getting all
the way to the rim wall gets the steal
and went quite a past reporter and he
scores that fast ten seconds this huge
wall get the screen they find God John
Wall with five seconds
by two the two at free throws number
four field goal number two of points in
the paint this beautiful jumper with all
kind of confident Lopez had to give them
some space and I always had a steel wall
didn't see that one coming now they
can't get the steel wall pushing it up
court left-handed slam
[Applause]
lighting plays Wizards on a slapping
nothing run tying their largest lead in
the game is back
and the buzzer another spectacular move
by John Wall to finish off the Celtics
and the end of the corner for behind the
back dribble under control now the
step-back
Olynyk couldn't even react just if
taunted tonight wall Beal Corktown who
hasn't missed what drives for the slam
and he's fouled on the play where he
loves submit is what that left hand has
explosive lead off the right foot off
the right leg and Bradley Beal excited
about the finish job but they don't get
that one wall the other way spins goes
to the glass and lays it in
have cut it to chew after they trailed
by eight wall another spectacular play
I'm a little bit better more okay with
that I thought they would give up a
second round in order to make the
acquisition
[Applause]
rid of Andrew Niccol C's contract helps
them one well put breath we saw Gazoo
well they you took it back the drive of
the game
[Music]
what a move by wall and then he baked
you go pear job by John walk take away
that bastard Lane wall drives flips
one-up score the field goal and he'll go
to the line he had a little bit of
daylight so he stepped through that
daylight there they are there he steps
doing flips it up as he's falling down
[Applause]
yeah I actually headed back to the
basket momentarily but again they've got
a number of shooters that can knock that
shot down wall into the
nobody's stopping him this could be a
Miller time moment John gets into Lane
[Applause]
wall drives for slabs it
[Applause]
let's change a direction and then here
the body control and able to finish over
the extended hands of how easy pointed
out in the games they've lost in this
series they've not shot the ball well
for 3 Peter team in the series a shot
him oh wow
John Wall says get out of my way as he
goes to the rim soars and slides and
then cupped it with the left hand and
dunked on the defender see getting that
right foot watch what happens here
bunking with the left hand and you know
a lot of times that happens with a guy
when he's having some leg problems or
whatever he starts playing up to the
other leg and use it to turn the game
for them Ayers wall beautiful rigid
finish he does it on both ends trying to
will the Wizards to the second round
Boston now 8 of 17 from three-point
territory wall the cross the stick
[Applause]
it's got incredible vision you think
there's nowhere to go and then here with
the vision not just to see it look at it
feet the foot control here or should be
he gets tripped but still the strength
and presence to deliver a scoring pass
that was most impressive was spinning
like a top this is down inside also not
that far away from the basket right
around Olynyk right there how about that
Bo Porter can't find anybody
it gives it to all market gets Bradley
for three
[Applause]
shot
now you talk about a precious shot that
was it
he's anion and now watch the left side
here's this screen this is what they're
they stop that and John Wall comes up
and gets the ball in rhythms John wall
says Avery Bradley I got a little
something for you here
now your Boston you have three and a
half seconds Malcolm Brogdon and walky
bucks
and throws it down with a left hand
if it was the other way around that
would be a charge on him instead wall
gets away with it hammers it down
that's a Status nod call Mike
[Music]
you do not have to get two technicals to
be objective while at the other end at
the buzzer what a hand for Washington
wool you see the clock winding down
launches and scores the floor with no
call here's Ingram the other way and
that's rejected by Beal around the wall
and Beal has it let's start with the
block Brandon Ingram with no clue and
his John Wall says no sir I mean you
know he just doesn't see quick John Wall
with that rejection laws jumper good
[Music]
your nightly for superboots by John Wall
look at that
I am me complaining that the basketball
is in the cylinder on that block and a
technical foul faces out and makes them
pay motion sets up for three hit ship
been waiting for this block and then
it's off to the races Ty Lawson you said
it buck he's been hot from beyond the
three-point arc Oh rock solid first two
games of his play on pair of seven for
tens if I'm not mistaken he insane
same stats both games
of the Rosen thinks he's by him spy
telling you brain but he's not by John
Wall great help on the back side the
defense tonight markedly better for the
wizards in the health again last year
limited to only 31 games played at
they're torn meniscus in his knee while
he has had a couple of electrifying
ducks in his first half that big man
down low has to come across too much
sooner if you're gonna get there before
John Wall does inside Vukovich knocked
away the wizards have it again here's
wall over the timeline wall behind his
back it's a one-point game spectacular
play by John Wall who's having scored a
point now in over three minutes and
another turnover this time by Howard I
mean on the other side but there's
breath there's John Wall as you said
self-proclaimed best defensive guard in
history but we've got a foul call watch
Aminu John Wall is gonna put this ball
up on the glass watch the white Howard
coming in over the top no call wall down
court behind his back lays it up and
then with the foul what a play by John
Wall I mean this is all he could do I
think John said don't play with me now
Honda Drive of the game James Ennis
behind the back to avoid the defender
then taking the contact excellent timing
and just a flailing James Ennis that
gets the foul it's a pretty good play
for mr. now hustle Kyle Kuzma to get
that board Wizards pick it off again
it's Troy brown with a pass to wall who
goes back to Dekker
by the Wizards in transition two seconds
for wall backs up for the long jumper at
the buzzer John Wall slaps five with the
fans on the court
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everything going right for wall on the
Wizards here in the first walls mystic
shots in twenty attempts and a block by
wall sends it into the crowd in the
front row what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content